a cluster of massive great white sharks
is gathering off the coast of the
Carolinas this morning they're some of
the same sharks that researchers have
been tracking for more than a decade Meg
Oliver's in Wrightsville Beach North
Carolina to show us the resurgence of
the vulnerable animals Meg good morning
Vlad good morning researchers tell me
the Sharks are as close as 20 miles off
the coast here great whites can reach
about 4,000 pounds and 17 feet long and
their numbers along the Atlantic coast
are on the rise these are the sharks
that have been spending the past week
off the coastline of the Carolinas and
they even have names Cabot Hal Jane
Jefferson Brunswick and last but not
least luna a 15-footer who weighs in at
more than 2,000 pounds a 15-foot long
white shark is pretty close to a
full-grown as as large as they would
ever find it it's almost like a small
car yes yes so if you were to basically
walk next to it you would have a long
ways to go before you get from tail
that's a no there's a reason Luna and
her friends are so well known they're
being tracked by dr. Robert Hugh dur a
senior scientist for the ocean research
organization Oh search CBS this morning
was there when he and his first team
tagged their first great white in the
North Atlantic in 2012 in our studies we
have tagged about 43 sharks and six of
the largest ones are off of the
Carolinas are not right up close to the
beach so no worries for the swimmers
pewter and his team have been studying
the Sharks migration patterns around the
world Luna for instance is at a typical
migration moving south to the warmer
waters of Florida between October and
December and now making her way back up
north for the summer these sharks have
been coming here for millennia as long
as the East Coast the United States has
existed these sharks have been in our
waters there's something else here that
could also be encouraging these sharks
to stick around so one of the really
unique aspects off the North Carolina
coast is we have thousands of shipwrecks
experts say the shipwrecks provide
artificial reefs that thousands of fish
now call home
so when sharks come in there's big fish
small fish this whole food chain that
exists on all these wrecks I do believe
we're seeing more sharks come back
because of the protections that are in
place so it's a conservation success
story a success story indeed now the
next part of this journey for these
sharks is up the coast as far north as
Newfoundland shark attacks are rare but
you can take precautions they're
attracted to shiny jewelry colorful
swimsuits and the risks are greater at
night than during the day John all right
Meg Oliver thank you so much meg I just
have to know when I'm in the water don't
wear my yellow tankini yes no shiny
drool my yellow yes yes and make sure
that Tony and leave the fanny pack of
Chama
[Laughter]